l'héroïne est magistrale le jeu
captivant diront les experts en tout cas
netflix rassurer un coup de maître
plus de 60 millions de téléspectateurs
dès le premier mois pour une série sur
les tournois d'échecs du jamais de
queens jeu de la dame en français est
basé sur un roman de 1983 c'est
l'histoire d'une jeune orpheline devenu
prodige des jeux d'échecs
cet épisode qui nous transporte dans les
années 50 et 60 où s'entrechoquent les
pièces les narcotiques l'alcool avec une
dame déterminer qui avance vers la
gloire et dans le film est les coups
sont bons tout c'est les positions
qu'ils ont déjà été joués il ya des
grands maîtres ont été consultés pour
pour créer ses positions l'eau miley
jade ouellette josé cheikh depuis l'âge
de 5 ans comme dans la série ses
adversaires sont surtout de jeunes
hommes
puis vers l'âge de 7 ans j'ai commencé à
jouer dans des tournois réguliers au
québec y avait parmi les jeunes
mais si vers 9 ans que j'ai commencé
avec j'ai commencé à jouer dans des
tournois québécois tout âge confondu
l'année dernière elle a remporté le
championnat d'échecs au mexique
décrochant le titre de grand maître
international féminin chez quelqu'un
d'assez logés qui aiment se pense et se
débattre s'abstenait de tout ces styles
l'appui c'est vraiment une question de
qui que le mieux calculer qui s'est plus
concentré qui a réussi à faire des
manoeuvres des plantes qui était
meilleur que son adversaire
c'est vraiment c'est assez compétitifs
et très compétitive en général
depuis la diffusion de la série
l'engouement pour lés jeux d'échecs est
internationale c'est pour exiger oui
entre quelques rands déchets sur une
base régulière presque 9 clients sur 10
qui a rang dans la boutique c pour les
échecs et c'est un regain qui c'est
comme un réveil je vous gardez pas
pleuvoir plastique cas membres ici à la
boutique stratégie l'intérêt pour les
cours aussi c'est multiplier dans les
trois quatre dernières semaines le
téléphone n'arrête pas de sonner
on a autant des parents qui est des
adultes qui soudainement un grand
intérêt pour le jeu d'échecs
les cours sont en ligne à cause de la
pandémie mais il demeure populaire comme
apprendre à jouer de la muse est qu à
prendre un langage
ça ouvre d'autres parties de notre
cerveau qu'on n'utilise pas
nécessairement je me sens en sécurité
dans un monde de 64 quasi l'héroïne du
film en temps de pandémie de confinement
un monde de 64 cases semble être le
parfait exutoire ici assez votre rigueur
guise radio canada montréal
dans le monde